In the whole of Russian history, there have
been a mere handful of men to earn the nickname
“the great”.
But there has only ever been one woman.
Catherine the Great was an empress who defied
both her circumstances and the opinions of
those around her to shape an entire era.
Born into a minor German family in the first
half of the 18th Century, she found herself
thrust into the spotlight when she married
Peter III of Russia aged only 16.
But rather than being a pushover, Catherine
used her new position to grab the imperial
crown for herself.
Empress of Russia from 1762 to 1796, Catherine’s
reign spanned global conflicts and revolutions,
uprisings and royal assassinations.
But she never lost sight of her goal: to forge
a modern Russia from the ideals of the Enlightenment.
A philosopher empress to some, an amoral,
sex-obsessed harlot to others, this is the
life of one of Russia’s greatest rulers.
An Unlikely Ruler
To say Catherine the Great’s path to the
throne was an unlikely one is a little bit
like saying Siberia gets a bit chilly in winter.
At the moment she was born Sophie Friederike
Auguste on May 2, 1729, the likelihood of
Catherine becoming ruler of Russia was up
there with me one day becoming emperor of
Japan.
By the way Tokyo, if the new guy doesn’t
work out, do give me a call.
Young Sophie - who we’re just gonna start
calling Catherine right now to avoid confusion
- didn’t have a drop of Russian blood in
her.
Rather, her father was a minor German prince,
while her mother Joanna was a slightly-less
minor aristocrat who had ideas above her station.
And those ideas emphatically did not involve
having a daughter.
From the moment Joanna discovered she’d
pumped out not a useful male heir but a useless
girl, she treated Catherine less like a human
and more like a receptacle for all her disappointments.
Joanna called her daughter useless, ugly,
told her she was worthless.
It probably didn’t help that Joanna herself
was a mere 17 when she became a mother, and
that her arranged marriage to Catherine’s
much-older dad hadn’t exactly been a fairytale.
It probably also didn’t help that Catherine
went out of her way to confirm Joanna’s
fears.
She was clumsy.
Accident prone.
There’s a story that she once managed to
dislocate her spine just by sneezing.
Yet, even amid all these excursions into klutz
territory, it was clear there was something
more to Catherine than Joanna gave her credit
for.
When she was just four, she met the future
king Frederick the Great.
Told to kiss his hem as a mark of respect,
she instead demanded the royal bow down to
her so she could reach.
Frederick was so tickled by this that he never
forgot the confident young girl.
Yet it would be another encounter that really
defined Catherine’s childhood.
A grandson of Peter the Great, Peter Ulrich
was a mere 11 when he and 10-year old Catherine
met, and about as far from his famous grandfather
as can be imagined.
While Peter the Great had ruled Russia, Peter
Ulrich was German through and through.
While Peter the Great had been a dashing warrior-reformer,
his grandson was sickly and neurotic.
He was also deeply damaged.
Left in the care of a sadistic tutor, Peter
Ulrich had spent his life being beaten, tortured,
and humiliated by the adult meant to care
for him.
He was made to stand at the dining table,
a picture of a donkey hung around his neck.
Made to endure savage whippings for the tiniest
infraction.
As our video unfolds today, Peter Ulrich is
going to take a role best essentially as the
villain.
As he does so, just remember that the abuse
he suffered as a child is at least partly
to blame.
Despite their differences, Catherine and Peter
hit it off during their first meeting, becoming
not exactly friends, but maybe friendly acquaintances.
Still, there’s no way Catherine could’ve
known just what fate had in store for them.
No way she could’ve know that this sickly,
troubled lad was the future emperor she was
destined to overthrow.
The Empire of Ice
On the frozen night of December 5, 1741, a
group of guards marched into the bedchamber
of Russia’s infant emperor Ivan VI and arrested
him and his mother, Anna Leopoldovna.
By the morning of December 6, both mother
and child had been locked away and Moscow
had a new ruler.
The daughter of Peter the Great, Empress Elizabeth
was the Imelda Macros of the 18th Century,
a woman obsessed with clothes, spectacle,
and living the good life on the state budget.
She surrounded herself with pomp and fawning
courtiers, and forbade anyone but herself
from wearing pink.
But for our story today, the defining feature
of Elizabeth was that she was childless.
Not long after her coup against Ivan, Elizabeth
decided to bag herself an heir by inviting
Peter Ulrich to Moscow to be her son.
Two years later, in 1743, a letter landed
in the hands of Catherine’s mother, Joanna.
From Empress Elizabeth, it invited Joanna
to come and see Moscow along with her darling
daughter.
Shortly after, another letter arrived, this
one from Frederick the Great, filled with
subtle hints that the Prussian king could
help Joanna marry her daughter off.
Suddenly, it looked like Catherine was going
to Russia.
For Joanna, this was the fairytale she’d
been waiting for her whole married life.
She immediately set about spending the money
Frederick had forwarded on fancy dresses and
heaps of jewelry.
Not for Catherine, but for herself.
Joanna wanted to look her absolute best on
the day she dumped her useless daughter on
some unsuspecting Russian prince.
By winter, 1743, Joanna and Catherine were
on the road to St Petersburg.
If you’re wondering how Catherine felt about
being whisked away to marry some dude she
barely knew, the answer is that it didn’t
matter.
This was Europe in the 18th century.
Arranged marriages were the norm in the upper
classes.
And, aged only 14, Catherine had grown into
a very desirable bachelorette.
She was witty.
Confident.
Disarming.
Although she wasn’t a legendary beauty,
she was already fighting off marriage proposals
- not least from Joanna’s own brother.
Awkward.
Finally, after a very long, very cold journey,
Catherine and Joanna arrived in Moscow.
The imperial welcome they received was so
big, so lavish that it left no-one in doubt
about Catherine’s future role in the empire.
Now all she had to do was actually meet Peter
again after all these years.
A Match Made in Hell
If Catherine had grown up to be a charmer,
Peter Ulrich had grown up to be the exact
opposite; a miserable black hole that sucked
all the joy out any room.
The boy hated Russia.
He hated Elizabeth, he hated Moscow, and he
hated the fact he wasn’t in his beloved
Prussia.
At first, the arrival of the German Catherine
was a relief.
Finally, someone who could understand his
misery!
But while Peter’s idea of a good time was
writing fan letters to Frederick the Great
and discussing how superior bratwurst was
to borscht, Catherine’s was very different.
From the moment she arrived in Russia, the
teenage girl had fallen in love.
The Russia of the 1740s was a distant, mysterious
place, almost entirely rural, with only a
handful of cities.
The religion was not the Lutheranism Catherine
had grown up with, but the exotic Orthodox
rites of Eastern Christianity.
For this girl from Germany, it was an alien
land.
A place of endless, fascinating contrasts.
And, much to Peter’s annoyance, Catherine
was determined to fit in.
She began studying Russian, began her conversion
to Orthodoxism.
By the time she debuted at court on her 15th
birthday, the upper classes were ready to
love her.
It helped that Catherine could be just as
charming in Moscow as at home.
She always had a killer quip ready, or a well-thought
out compliment to disarm strangers with.
She even got a reputation for treating her
servants as kindly as her upper crust friends,
something of a big deal at the time.
Before long, Elizabeth had bestowed the title
Grand Duchess upon her, along with the name
Catherine (or Yekaterina in Russian).
But while the empress seemed to have made
a good choice in Catherine, she’d made a
much worse one in her heir.
As Catherine grew more popular at court, Peter
grew crueler towards her.
He told her he was going to beat her once
they were married, as that was the only way
to control a woman.
Started getting drunk and verbally abusing
her.
But as bad as Peter was already, he was about
to get so much worse.
Not long before their wedding, Peter came
down with a case of smallpox, a disfiguring
disease we’d really advise against Googling.
It took him six weeks to recover.
When he finally did, his face was so scarred
that Catherine couldn’t bring herself to
look at him.
Bitter, angry, and miserable, Peter retreated
from the world, locking himself in his rooms
and refusing to do anything but dress his
servants in Prussian army uniforms and play
soldiers.
He only really emerged for the lavish wedding
on August 21, 1745.
But even then, his bitterness got the better
of him.
Early in the evening, Catherine was sent by
Elizabeth to the marital bed to await Peter
and get on with the job of producing heirs.
Instead, Catherine lay there for hours in
the dark, waiting for her new husband.
When Peter finally turned up, he was so drunk
he simply collapsed.
Not a word.
Not a kiss.
Not even a joke.
Just one unhappy teenager passed out on the
floor, and another unhappy teen likely wondering
if this marriage had ruined her life.
Well, if Catherine ever did wonder that, she
was wrong.
As toxic as her marriage was, it would wind
up making her into a figure remembered by
history.
She just had to survive the next few years
first.
Intimacy and Intrigue
By late 1745, Elizabeth’s enthusiasm for
Catherine had distinctly cooled.
There still hadn’t been any royal heirs,
so Elizabeth wrote Catherine a stern note
reminding her she better get knocked up fast.
But there was very little Catherine could
do about it.
By now, Peter was actively avoiding sex, preferring
to play with his toy soldiers and live in
a fantasy world.
One evening Catherine came into their room
to find him putting a rat he’d caught on
trial.
When she asked him what he was doing, he declared
the rat guilty and sliced off its head.
In the wake of this incident it’s perhaps
not surprising that Catherine started an affair.
Today, Catherine’s affairs are legendary.
But we’ll come to all that.
For now, just know she started sleeping with
a guy called Sergei Saltykov, possibly in
an attempt to get pregnant, and possibly with
Peter’s knowledge.
Yet, try as she might, Catherine just couldn’t
become the baby-producing machine Elizabeth
wanted her to be.
Oh, she got pregnant all right.
Multiple times.
But she always miscarried.
Before anyone knew what was happening, nine
years had passed, and Catherine was still
not a mother.
That finally changed on October 1, 1754.
That day, baby Paul was born at the end of
a labor best described as “arduous.”
The moment the baby was out, Elizabeth came
in and snatched it away to raise herself.
Catherine, for her part, was left lying alone
in her own blood for hours, too weak to move.
With her heir-producing duties now over, Catherine
entered a new, depressing stage in her life
at the Russian court.
Now the baby was here, everyone just started
ignoring her.
They held a party to celebrate Paul’s birth
while Catherine was still convalescing.
All she got was a drunk Peter sticking his
head in the door and muttering something like
“err, well done,” before going back to
the party.
Had Catherine been another woman, it’s possible
her story would’ve ended here, finally beaten
down by her awful new family.
But this is Catherine we’re talking about.
A woman who has “the Great” in her name.
Rather than give up, she spent her convalescence
reading Voltaire and plotting her return to
court.
On Peter’s birthday, she finally managed
it.
Kitted out in the finest regalia, Catherine
crashed the party, inviting herself in unannounced
and restyling herself “mother of the heir”.
With breathtaking confidence, she casually
snubbed those who’d ignored her after her
labor.
Dropped deliciously poisonous witticisms about
anyone who tried to stand up to her.
From that point on, Catherine would never
let herself get isolated again.
She cozied up to the British ambassador, accepting
bribes in return for information, bribes she
used to buy herself a network of informants.
As the 1750s swept by, Catherine began buttering
up people in positions of power.
Leaders of army units, aristocrats, anyone
who might one day be useful.
By the end of the decade, she’d even taken
two important lovers: Stanisław Poniatowski,
the future king of Poland, and Grigory Orlov,
the man who’d make her empress.
But, powerful as she now was, Catherine was
still vulnerable.
When she gave birth to her second child, Anna,
Peter came and watched the whole thing, drunk
out his skull, declaring that he could do
anything to her.
It must’ve been a chilling thing to hear.
It also steeled Catherine’s resolve.
If she ever wanted peace, she was going to
have to get rid of her husband once and for
all.
The Battle for Power
In 1756, a war broke out that engulfed half
the world.
Known as the Seven Years’ War it involved
most of the European powers, including pitting
Russia against Prussia
But bad as the Seven Years’ War was, it
was nothing compared to the battle brewing
in the Russian court.
By 1762, Peter had begun a public affair with
Elizaveta Vorontsova, a coarse woman of coarser
manners.
On top of that, he was parading around wearing
Prussian uniforms and telling everyone they
shouldn’t be fighting Frederick the Great.
He was even promising Catherine that, as soon
as he became emperor, he would have her shaved
bald and thrown in a convent.
It was a threat that was about to become very
real.
On January 5, 1762, Empress Elizabeth breathed
her last.
In the wake of her death, Peter was elevated
to the throne as Peter III.
One of his first acts was to spend Elizabeth’s
funeral procession openly celebrating her
death.
His second act was to make his popular, unwanted
wife suffer.
In the months that followed, Peter III began
inflicting humiliation after humiliation on
Catherine.
He forced her to personally award medals to
his mistress Elizaveta, dragged her out in
public and tried to make her confess that
their son Paul was illegitimate.
But it wasn’t just Catherine Peter was getting
his vengeance on.
For so long, he’d hated Russia.
And now he was in charge, he was going to
dismantle the whole damn country.
Church property was stripped and given to
Lutheran ministeries.
Army units were forced to drink toasts to
Frederick the Great.
Everything became pro-Prussian, anti-Russian,
and very anti-Catherine.
For Catherine, those months must’ve been
a nightmare.
Luckily, she was about to wake up.
That summer, July 8, Catherine’s lover Grigory
Orlov abruptly came to her and basically said
“let’s throw this asshole over.
Right now.”
And so they did.
The coup was organized by Orlov with the help
of his brothers and a guy called Grigory Potemkin,
who we’re gonna come back to soon.
It was simple and bloodless.
Dressed in a male uniform, Catherine rode
out to meet army units loyal to her.
As they joined, more declared their loyalty,
until it was clear no-one in Moscow stood
against her.
Finally, on July 9, 1762, Catherine was declared
Empress Catherine II.
And that was that.
Well, almost.
Just outside Moscow, Peter was drilling some
of his troops when word came in of the coup.
But it wasn’t just news that was traveling
in Peter’s direction.
Catherine was riding out at the head of an
army.
So Peter did the only thing he could: he abdicated
and threw himself on his wife’s mercy.
Apparently, he hoped to be sent into exile
in Prussia.
But Catherine was all like “nah,” and
had him placed under house arrest.
8 days later, Peter was dead.
The historical record isn’t clear on what
killed poor, damaged Peter Ulrich.
Officially, it was a nasty bout of hemorrhoids.
Unofficially, it’s thought he was strangled
on the orders of Orlov.
Whatever the truth, the result was the same.
On September 22, 1762, Catherine was crowned
empress of Russia in a lavish ceremony at
the Kremlin.
The anonymous girl from Germany had finally
done it.
She’d survived the intrigues of the Russian
court, survived her marriage to a madman,
and smashed through the glass ceiling as effectively
as a tomahawk missile.
Now came the hard part.
An Instruction for Change
In 1767, Catherine sent her legislative committee
a simple Instruction.
Known as the Instruction of Catherine the
Great, it set out her vision for the future.
Under her watch, Russia would conform to the
ideals of the Enlightenment.
Things like innocent until proven guilty would
become law.
The common good would be emphasized.
The country’s 8 million serfs would be considered
people.
To our ears, this can sound a little “well,
duh.”
But in 18th Century Russia it was a bombshell.
Even other European powers were aghast.
France actually banned copies of the Instruction
to avoid a revolution.
Yeah, good luck with that.
But while Catherine’s ideas were revolutionary,
her implementation of them was not.
Rather than act like good little Enlightenment
thinkers, her committee fell to squabbling.
Then war broke out and the whole idea was
completely forgotten.
The Russo-Turkish War decimated Catherine’s
domestic agenda between 1768 and 1774, but
at least it shored up her power, helped by
the capture of Crimea.
Still, by the time the dust had settled, Catherine
was 12 years into her rule and had accomplished
only a fraction of what she wanted to do.
So she dropped any pretence of governing by
committee.
From now on, she was going to force her reforms
through by personal decree.
And what reforms they were.
Catherine opened the first schools for orphans,
the first hospitals for the destitute.
She encouraged girls into education, at a
time when most households valued women somewhere
below horses and about equal with good footwear.
City governments were reformed to better serve
the people.
The police were transformed from an instrument
for repression into one that at least nominally
helped ordinary folk.
Then there were the great cities Catherine
built, like the port of Odessa, where skilled
immigrants were invited in to transform the
economy.
She even undertook the first detailed mapping
of Russia.
There’s a great story that Catherine was
in a meeting where a far-flung town was discussed.
When Catherine asked where it was, all her
advisors shrugged.
So she sent someone out to buy a map.
When they came back, she discovered that not
even the map makers had bothered to map most
of Russia.
You better believe that changed pretty sharpish.
But while Catherine’s reforms brought Russia
into line with its European neighbors, they
weren’t all successful.
Remember how her Instruction called for the
country’s 8 million serfs to be considered
people?
Those serfs were basically slaves, tied to
the land and owned by local landlords.
When Catherine realized her core support came
from those same landlords, she did an about
face and actually increased serfdom.
This touches on the other issue of who benefited
from Catherine’s reforms.
We mentioned earlier that 18th Century Russia
was about 95% rural.
Yet the vast majority of Catherine’s reforms
were in urban areas.
As transformative as her domestic agenda was,
millions of Russians didn’t even realize
it was happening.
Still, her reforms got her noticed abroad,
where people like Voltaire championed her
as a great philosopher empress.
But Catherine’s reputation would soon become
international news again for a very different
reason.
It’s time to talk about sex.
Love & Death
So far in this video, we’ve met three of
Catherine’s lovers: the guy who possibly
fathered Paul; the guy who became King of
Poland; and Orlov, the guy who probably strangled
Peter III.
Now it’s time to meet the most-famous of
them all.
Grigory Potemkin had been a background character
in Catherine’s life for decades.
He’d helped Orlov organize the coup that
overthrew Peter III.
In the Russo-Turkish War, he’d been the
one who secured Crimea.
And now he was back in the imperial court,
determined to charm his way into power.
To say Catherine and Potemkin were suited
to one another is to miss just how perfectly
they matched.
Potemkin was ambitious, fearless.
Not exactly handsome, but attractive in a
“this guy does not give two flying flips”
sort of way.
His ambition also complemented Catherine’s.
While Catherine was happy to lose herself
in details, Potemkin was a big picture thinker,
able to spur her dreams to greater heights.
Catherine summoned him to court in 1774.
Before the year was out, they were lovers.
There’s even some evidence to suggest they
married in a secret ceremony, inside a tiny,
backwater church with only two witnesses.
It’s certainly true she named him Prince
Potemkin, and elevated him to a status nearly
equal to co-ruler.
But while their burning ambition is what brought
Catherine and Potemkin together, it was also
what killed their love.
By 1780, both were fully aware that their
love of power was corrupting their romantic
relationship.
So they made a deal.
From now on, Potemkin would remain as Catherine’s
political advisor.
But in the bedroom, he would be replaced - not
with another ambitious, powerful man, but
with a string of anonymous studs.
And so we come to the one thing about Catherine
the Great that everyone remembers: her sexual
escapades.
The fact this is monstrously unfair goes without
saying.
Catherine’s contemporary, Louis XV, had
so many mistresses he could give Prince a
run for his money.
Selim III had an actual harem.
But, of course, it’s the highly-sexed woman
who goes down in history as using a horse
to satisfy herself, as story as fake now as
it was then.
Stay classy, 18th Century propagandists.
Still, there’s no denying that Catherine’s
reputation abroad really did take a beating
in the back end of her reign, and not just
because of ill-founded sex rumors.
In 1789, that revolution France had been trying
to avoid finally broke out, based on a lot
of those same Enlightenment ideals Catherine
professed to love.
But now that those ideals were questioning
the divine right of monarchs, Catherine was
suddenly all like “What Enlightenment?
Voltaire?
Never heard of him.”
When Poland began agitating for a French-style
liberal constitution in 1792, she forced the
Second Partition on the kingdom, dividing
most of it up between herself, Austria, and
Prussia.
When Tadeusz Kościuszko led a rebellion against
the partition two years later, Catherine cracked
down as hard as any tyrant.
In Warsaw, some 20,000 Poles were executed
in a single day - more people than died during
the entire Reign of Terror.
By the time Catherine instigated the Third
Partition of Poland in 1795, wiping the nation
off the map, her Enlightenment credentials
had been reduced to a hollow punchline.
But by then it barely mattered.
Grigory Potemkin had died in 1791, leaving
Catherine isolated and lonely.
In his place, the empress had begun to devote
all her attention to her grandson Alexander,
even hinting that she would pass her son Paul
over for succession.
Naturally, this created a deep rift in the
imperial family, and left Paul eager to get
one over on his mother.
On November 5, 1796, Catherine was found on
the floor of her bathroom, almost carried
off by a stroke.
The very next day she died, her grandson Alexander
still too young to take over from her.
In his place, Paul I ascended to the throne.
And he quickly set about trashing his mother’s
legacy.
The first thing he did was have all her papers
burned, just in case she’d written him out
her will.
Then he had poor Peter Ulrich dug back up
and given the state funeral Catherine had
denied him.
Finally, he ordered his mother buried alongside
his father.
After spending the early part of their lives
entwined in a toxic marriage, Catherine would
now spend eternity alongside her hated husband,
too.
At the moment of her death, Catherine must’ve
wondered how history would remember her.
Sure, she’d expanded Russian territory,
adding around 520,000 square kilometers.
Sure, she’d brought in liberal reforms and
modernized urban Russia.
But, at the same time, she’d failed in her
goal to abolish serfdom, just as she’d failed
to institute reforms that improved life for
the 95% of the population who lived outside
the cities.
So why, then, do we remember her as Catherine
the Great?
Well, from our modern perspective, it’s
easy to see why.
Just listen to her life story: a provincial
girl who overcame a parental neglect, a forced
marriage and an abusive husband to become
one of the most powerful women in Europe.
But even in the 18th Century, it was clear
that Catherine was someone special.
With her liberal reforms, she opened the door
for a Russia that existed to help its citizens,
not brutalize them.
While that door would be slammed shut again
by successive regimes, knowledge of what lay
behind it never really went away.
All those utopian revolutionaries.
All those moments of thaw in the 20th Century.
Those shuddering moves towards openness in
the 1980s.
All were distant descendants of Catherine’s
attempts to mould her country in a kinder
image.
She may not have always succeeded in her goals,
but Catherine deserves to be remembered by
her title.
She really was the greatest empress in Russian
history.